hello everybody
vino thank you for being here today
welcome back to the gsb
oh it's always fun to be here and it's a
lot nicer than when i was here
yes i've been hearing that quite a bit
today given the previous class are here
i'm thrilled to be having this
conversation um
i was told that you schedule your time
in 15-minute slots so we are taking up
four of those slots right now
so i'll get right to it um i have a few
questions here focusing on three things
your leadership and management journey
your thoughts on investing in
entrepreneurship and then a few
questions on your personal life and
legacy
after that we'll take a few questions
from audience and from twitter
um as dean selona mentioned you were the
founder and the first ceo at sun
microsystems
about a year after you had started
you found out that some microsystems was
going to be shut out from a key sale
when you heard this you got on a flight
got to the customer's lobby and made
phone calls refusing to leave until you
met with the team
where does this perseverance and
conviction come from
well um
so
i have a philosophy in life
whatever i believe
i should make happen it's that simple
and if a customer is making a mistake
the customer isn't always right trust me
and if you want to do great products
don't listen to your customers by the
way lots of bad lessons in business
school
i used to give a talk in the 80s on why
not to listen to your customers
and maybe somebody will ask me a
question
that story is in fact true
there was a signed contract with a
competitor
i stayed in the lobby
all day at six o'clock in the evening
and i'd taken a red eye out
and i parked in lobby i met with the ceo
of the company mostly because he wanted
me to go away
by nine o'clock he had i'd convinced him
to meet me in chicago with his team the
next day because he didn't want to be
seen negotiating with us
the following morning the day after at 5
a.m we signed a handwritten contract
because i wouldn't let him leave
this was the ceo of a big east coast
company computer vision
so we signed a handwritten contract and
life was good
the point is if you actually believe
something
you try your best to make it happen it
doesn't always happen but it happens
most of the time most the business
school entry story is also true
i actually
learned that somebody had dropped out
that's why i showed up
and one of the nice ladies in the
business school office put me in her
living room to her husband's chagrin she
was real nice to me
but things do work out if you process
not always
but i like to say failure does not
matter
it's success that matters and nobody
remembers
what you feel that so everybody
remembers son
does anybody know a company i started
before sun that mcnealy and i started
together any hands
well i do but i've been researching you
for a while now
what do you think the company is was the
data down yes there was a company called
datadump we started and got funded three
months before sun
didn't work out
we started both roughly together
but my point is people don't remember
your failures
and i like to say my willingness to fail
is what gives me the ability to succeed
i find
most people
are so afraid of failing they don't try
and do the things that would be
important enough to do
anything worth doing is hard
and so and you've spoken in the past
about the importance of failure or the
lack of it
you started your first company at age 20
in delhi
which did not work out as expected well
i didn't actually get started
they told me it'd be seven years to get
a phone line how did you react to that
honest to goodness
you know i was 19 or 20 and they told me
it would be a seven year waiting list to
get a
landline i i sort of
picked up and went to carnegie mellon
how was that like the move to the u.s
you know look
it was easy i wanted to be in silicon
valley i knew i'd get here i had no way
to pay for it so i had to figure out how
to get somebody to pay for it
in the end the biomedical engineering
department at cmu agreed to pay for it
so i went there and i was very
interested in biomedical engineering
so i did that and then applied
immediately to stanford and you've heard
the rest of the story they turned me
down a couple of times but
you know
the funny thing is with enough
persistence most things that seem
impossible
become possible
i'm always amazed at how often you can
turn things around
and people take no for an answer too
easily
you know it's whether you're trying to
achieve a goal like get into business
school
or
my green card was the same way i left
the job that had sponsored me but i
still got my green card even though no
lawyer would take me i became my own
lawyer
got my green card without working for
while i was at business school
and i did it perfectly legally i my
strategy there was if i couldn't
convince immigration i'd confuse them
and i did
and they gave me my green card
well
you know
i just want to ask you what are some
some other perhaps the early influences
that made you this way this high
perseverance high conviction person well
i was sort of always this way i didn't
grow up in this environment nobody
around my dad was in the indian army
since he was 16 so
he joined the ranks of the indian army
and when he was 16 got shipped off to
egypt to fight for the british and
so i grew up in a very
different environment but i always had
this view that
if i determined something was right i
was going to make it happen and this
comes to since one of the focuses of
this lecture is leadership
i am amazed at how few people have a
belief system what do they actually
believe in
um
i
and and yeah it's okay to offend you
guys
90 of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do
and
you know i even when i come to an event
like this say why am i here why would i
even bother to take an hour of my
valuable time
no it's true i i have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if i can convert
one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
i can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief
i'll have
i'll think of the hour as well spent
but
so i always say what am i trying to do
and why i don't speak because somebody
you know will write nice things about it
i always sort of have a purpose but i
have a belief system
and
most people even successful companies
and have big beef with fortune 500 ceos
i can talk about
there's very little leadership there
don't have an internal compass of what
they believe in
it's what do others expect
you know when i graduated
i went into entrepreneurship nobody went
into entrepreneurship out of the
business school and people said why
wouldn't you work
for goldman or mckinsey and i said why
would you
like i couldn't fathom why you would
want to
do that job
right
i still can't by the way
for those of you going to those places
and i'm sure there's plenty i'm probably
not the right person to talk to you
i frankly don't even care to talk to you
all of you others
i i think there's something wrong with
anybody who fundamentally wants to go
work for one of the consultants or the
investment banks today in this part
they don't understand how the world is
going to work in the future
but my point again is have a belief
system follow that compass
and i'm overstating it a bit so
there may be some hope for those of you
going there
but
it's only a little bit of an
exaggeration
let me go back to this issue of fortune
500 ceos
i've talked to many over the years
if a new york times writer writes an
article
they want to change their strategy they
want to respond
how silly is that that some english
major who's never had a business job can
determine the strategy of a fortune 500
company
why because they care about what's
written not what their belief system is
do you know what elon musk would say to
that writer go get a real job
right
what jeff bezos would say that's
leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do
not you're fitting in to do career
enhancement
or
making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your friends or to your
boss or to
shareholders
and frankly
you look at all the companies that are
languishing in the valley the older
companies
they generally don't have a belief
system they're generally trying to meet
some quarterly target without saying
here's how we will be different and
here's how we'll do it
apple did languish for 10 15 years and
then steve jobs came in with a point of
view and created the most valuable
company in the world he did irrational
things if you go back to january of 2007
january 1
everybody was saying nobody wants a
phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs 6.99 i
can go on with the litany
those were all english majors writing
articles i have this beef against
english majors
not all english majors are bad but the
majority of them at stanford are
undirected and don't have a goal or a
purpose
sorry
and that's not to say among them there
isn't 20 percent that are really good
they just didn't get the right guidance
and ended up in the wrong place
i like purposeful education anyway sorry
back to you no absolutely this is
there's actually is it interesting i
make up better questions than usually
well that's a challenge for you guys
hashtag gsbbfttt
but i want to ask you about this you are
known for being for the lack of a better
word somewhat blunt
well your website says we prefer brutal
honesty to hypocritical politeness
what are the trade-offs in doing this
well there's lots of trade-offs but
i'm i'm again very clear
you know it started off earlier in my
life i was very successful
even before i started sun i started a
company like daisy that made me more
money which was only a million dollars
back then or a little more than that
then my dad had made in the
in his career cumulatively so i was in a
whole different place
and i said the one thing i'll do is not
do what others want me to do or be
polite which generally means dishonest
there's a great book by sam harris who's
a professor over on the other side about
lying i recommend everybody read sam
harris's book online
and why we all lie too much and too
often
we put this
sort of slogan i prefer brutal honesty
to hypocritical politeness
on our website because it's a real
disservice to people
uh you don't have to be offensive to be
honest
when i don't like somebody i can't get
offensive to but generally you can be
constructive
and
very honest and i prefer that brutal
honesty
because it serves a purpose the receiver
can do something about it if it's
a constructive criticism
if you get hypocritical politeness you
might lose
a lot so again it's about having enough
confidence to say
the other person will eventually
appreciate it and that's logo slogan
came after
i was working on a company with another
major venture firm
and i didn't believe their plan would
work
they had
45 50 million dollars in the bank
account so everybody was comfortable too
comfortable in my view i talked to the
founders why it wouldn't work
what my concerns were
the other vcs agreed with me
in the board meeting said all these
polite things
you know so 40 engineers wasted three or
four years of their life
because nobody was willing to tell them
the honest truth about what they really
thought
i and i swore i would never let anybody
waste their life at least give them
the best advice i had to give
and tell them i may be wrong
but i'm not going to say something i
don't believe in
i just won't
and
and that's extremely valuable to the
other thing
but to be honest look there are
situations you keep it offends people
and i offend people often
but it helps them if they're really
introspective
right
i just had a candidate from howard
business school come in and interview
for a job and i
half an hour into the meeting i said you
know you're not a match for us
here's what i would do and i spent the
next half hour i said i literally said
to her if i'm gonna waste the next half
hour of my life
talking to you i'm going to give you my
best advice on what to do about your
career
which i did
she didn't love it she sent me a nice
note a week later
but it's very valuable
but the real fact the honest truth about
why i like that
is
once i was in a position i didn't need a
job
uh nobody could fire me i've actually
never worked for anybody so it's
actually sort of nice
i felt it was a indulgence or a luxury i
could enjoy
some people
if they make
get that financial freedom might buy a
yacht
i bought myself the freedom of brutal
honesty and it's an indulgence
i get to do things others may not be in
a position to do there is a downside for
others but i think generally
constructive honesty
and constructive criticism than
hypocritical politeness will serve other
people well
that founder by the way in that company
called me four years later
after after this company this company
got sold for three million dollars for
three and a half four years later
um
sad story and he called me a year after
that said i only want to work with you
on my next venture
because i wish somebody had told me
you mentioned you talked briefly about
venture capital as it stands now earlier
i just want to come back to that
specifically how does it compare to 1982
when you were starting some microsystems
and what are the major differences you
see
um
it's a lot more popular now it's a lot
more accepted
it's a lot more accepted to do startups
so
for those of you who are so inclined
it's much easier to take that route
uh
it wasn't back then so the risk of going
the entrepreneurial route was much
higher
if you rent entrepreneurial and it
didn't work out
you couldn't get a job at ge
right much harder
today if you've done a startup ge would
love to have you even if it failed
in fact would prefer you over somebody
who spent two years at ge
not a hundred percent true but
generally
it's the learning experience of a
startup whether it's successful or
unsuccessful is recognized as extremely
valuable
and the cultural training of that is
something everybody's striving for
i'm amazed at the people who come
through silicon valley
it feels like a tour stop like
fisherman's wharf used to be
every fortune 500 ceo coming here
holding board meetings here because they
want to learn the culture
and and i think that becomes a real
career enhancement for those of you who
do that
now i'm not a big fan of planning
careers and much more about
driving for the things you want to do
and go do them
and that's about entrepreneurship what
about venture capital i mean for
instance you very famously said in a
techcrunch interview 95 venture capital
is at no value and 70 percent had
negative value
all my venture capital friends loved
that statement
but i i tell them that you know there
was a major firm i called
uh somebody there and said
this guy's destroying this company right
it happens all the time
one is look
venture capital has become a big
business
it didn't used to be back then it was a
specialty art form there was a few firms
and most of them sequoia was started
with don valentine
if you know don he was an operator
kleiner was started by tom perkins and
eugene kleiner
tom ran a division of hp and before that
he was a technologist
these guys
and and i'm not one for looking back and
being romantic about these but this
issue is important
these guys earned the right to advise an
entrepreneur
that means they had gone through the
battles where they had the experience
when a unique situation came up and
entrepreneur wanted advice
they actually had been through the
firing line to viscerally understand
how to give them advice
most vcs have not earned the right to
advise an entrepreneur
yet they feel free to in their ignorance
and i believe you should have gone
through a startup
or at least some significant experiences
and they're good exceptions to this rule
to really advise entrepreneurs on how to
build a company
and most vcs haven't done that so they
give stupid advice
you know if you got out of business
school and joined a vc firm and grew up
and eventually became a partner you
haven't learned what it's like to be in
a startup
so in our firm we have a rule you can
join
you join for three to four years
then you have to leave actually work in
a startup before you come back and
actually can
get i'll give you the responsibility to
advise entrepreneurs
people get frustrated because their
peers in other venture firms are sitting
on boards and advising entrepreneurs
but
you know that's exercising authority as
opposed to exercising influence because
you have credibility with the
entrepreneur most time i don't go on
boards
i just advise entrepreneurs and frankly
being on the board is irrelevant
on that topic um you have a very unique
strategy among vcs you've said i'm only
interested in technologies that have a
90 chance of failure but if they do
succeed would change the infrastructure
of society in a radical way
how did you come to adopt this
particular strategy well so that's not
exactly accurate because we don't mind
low-risk technologies we invest in that
too
but
what i want to say is venture capital if
you think about it
isn't is not an irr business
you take any of the big successes google
facebook twitter
you can't predict that
you know camera like gopro can you
predict
the market cap you can't
and you can do spreadsheets so we don't
allow
any irr calculations in our firm nobody
does them nobody looks at them
in making investments we never calculate
an irr
because calculating an irr in my view is
creating the illusion of knowing which
big companies are very good at
you tweak some assumption
i did enough business plans to know i
can make the business plan do whatever i
want or the spreadsheet
you know reality is different i don't
even think you can plan startups so
business plans are largely irrelevant
other than in surfacing the key issues
the entrepreneur is thinking about
how thorough is their thinking what's
the quality of their thinking that's the
only thing i use a business plan for
then what you're doing
you're really doing
option value investing if you want a
financial term
if you lose you lose one times your
money if you win you win 10 times your
money your downside is limited to your
investment so whenever we make an
investment i assume we lost it and then
there's only upside
right as soon as you write it off in
your mind there's only upside
so
that's how i view the world and then you
try and take the higher risk and there's
vcs who won't invest with us because
they feel like we we take too much risk
which is fine there's room for every
style of vc firm
ours
is different it's about taking higher
risks and higher upside
90 chance of failure is not a problem
if there's a 10 chance of a hundred
times your money if it's the only thing
that worked
then you're in pretty good shape
and and and that's not the only good
strategy private equity does very well
running spreadsheets and
that i just have no interest in
spreadsheets so and we're not good at it
so we know what we do
what's bad is when people who come from
that world want to do this kind of
investing there can't be a mismatch of
your personality with the investing type
but all those are good scenarios and
some of them are even better scenarios
for irr than what we do
sorry you mentioned in your you
mentioned right now about getting other
vcs to invest with you um and throughout
your investing career you had a strong
streak of going against conventional
wisdom
next-gen juniper
um
i'm curious how do you get others to buy
into your convictions
uh sometimes they do after the fact
sometimes they don't
sometimes they actually don't know any
better so they're confused which is good
uh all those happen look there's lots of
really good
vcs around
right
but
there's order of magnitude more bad vcs
around
it's so there's probably half a dozen
people i respect in the vc business
and probably the vast majority i don't
know personally so i won't judge them
but of all the people i know in the vc
business 90
really add no value and i'm truly
believe 70 percent of them
reduce the potential of a company
i could i could keep asking you
questions on investing but i really
wanna but here's the thing right 90
chance of failure yeah
you have to have the courage to fail
that because most likely you're going to
to get that option at a very large play
and and that's
a particular segment of the venture
capital business or the investing
business it's not every segment capital
preservation is important in other
segments it's just boring to me it's
much more exciting to be on a roller
coaster
where the highs are high and the lows
are low
so
risk taking is absolutely essential now
as career advice to all of you
most
you can make money and good status and
all that in regular big companies
there's very little
really interesting stuff you can do in
big companies
it comes
shockingly
it's shocking to people
but who invent reinvented retail it
wasn't walmart
it was amazon
who reinvented media it wasn't nbc it
was youtube
who reinvented space it wasn't lockheed
it was spacex
i was hard-pressed
to think of one thing that had come out
of a large company in the last 20 30
years that was
materially changing the landscape
and the reason is very simple and this
is
all interesting things have
happened at the edges of the system
they don't happen in the solid core
and
all that you have to do where things are
fuzzy
unclear uncertain
if there's a market forecast it's not at
the edge of the system
if some analyst has a report
it's not worth
exp going into that area
right
i have a whole thing about analysts we
can get there
let's actually talk about it okay so i
asked me after i finished this
thought
in the edges where things are uncertain
is where
all the evolution is
and where interesting changes in
business
or society happen
and unless you're there
and learning fast from being there and
not being too arrogant to believe you
know what's going to happen
you're not going to be in that learning
edge of the wave
where new things are happening and as
career advice i say and that's where
failure happens often you want failure
to be small
and success to be very large which is
the characteristic of option value you
lose your option price but you get
option value if it's successful
that all happens at the edge
in automotive i assume
there was a ceo of uh in fact i've had
three ceos from the
10 largest auto companies come by in the
last six months
and i said i wouldn't worry about
building a better car
almost certainly 10 years from now
a volkswagen or toyota will be a
financing entity not a car making entity
there will not be the notion of
marketing to consumers
the auto industry as we know it i think
will disappear
disappear in the sense of ibm mainframes
is still around they're still a business
they're relatively static they're
filling an old need but
almost certainly the number of cars
produced 10 years from now will be less
than half of what is produced today
for sale to consumers
now
long we don't have enough time to go
into why i believe that
almost certainly
and i'm serious about this i gave a talk
at the stanford med school
and i said if i wanted to be a good
doctor in 15 20 years i wouldn't go to
the med school if i wanted to be a good
doctor i would go to the math department
almost certainly
every single thing they're learning
about medicine will be obsolete in 15
years
so you can join medtronic or ge medical
and do incremental things
or you can try to learn at the edges
where your probability of failure is
much high but the consequences of
success are really consequential
and most people in their life in their
business
reduce risk
to the point
where the probability of success goes
higher but the consequences of success
are inconsequential
as opposed to
reducing the probability of success
and increasing the consequences of
success which is sort of my life
philosophy trust me it's a lot more fun
than spending
30 years at goldman
the clark goldman you know that's a
fascinating world view but i really want
to get a question so let me go back to
okay
i i i just have streams of thought but
you did ask me to talk about the
analysts and the experts yeah the
experts
so professor tetlock when he was at
berkeley
did research on expert opinion
all the analysts you read
all the mckinsey reports
uh and by the way bain and pcg no
different
and he followed all their forecasts for
20 years
28 000 individual forecasts from 250
experts where when the forecast was made
he classified
what would be a success what would be a
failure
and the book is called expert political
judgment
so all these great studies
the 10-year studies mckinsey did for
millions of dollars for at t on what
would happen to the cell phone business
that's a fun story
across 28 000 individual forecasts in 84
000 possible scenarios
the average accuracy of the best experts
whether it was henry kissinger
tom friedman
mckinsey
your favorite
favorite economic forecaster the average
accuracy was about the same
to use his words
as dart throwing monkeys
so if you want to run your life on these
forecasts and create the illusion of
knowing great go do it
you'll follow a path that others will
reinforce because you can give them a
data quest study
or a bane forecast
or you can discover the edges where
things are happening and changing
know that you don't know
and really change the world now
again bringing back to leadership
it's about having a point of view it's
about having an internal compass this is
a great point in your life to actually
decide which one of those do you have a
belief system are you gonna do what
others tell you to do whether it's
written up in the new york times
which
uh which somebody wrote up who doesn't
understand the context whether it's a
mckinsey report or a ge forecast or a
goldman analyst
or you're going to do what you believe
in
and unfortunately
very few of you will do that
i hope i convert some of you to
believing in yourself
and
the good news is
i actually believe
five percent of the people is all that's
needed to be even remotely innovative to
change society
i once looked at
all social changes not just business
and i looked at a decade and i said for
people born between 1940 and 1950 or
1950
of all the people burned on this planet
if you take the 10
100 major areas
and defined could you find a hundred
people in each of those areas from that
decade that generation
who affected change it didn't matter
whether it was music
arts
research in social sciences technology
invention
business
you can't find a hundred areas and you
cannot find a hundred people that stand
out in each of these areas in any given
decade
so less than ten thousand people born
this decade will influence
all of what society
does think
happen
i'd like to say you should try and be
one of those people
and none of those people will follow any
analyst forecast
they will have an internal compass
they'll have self-confidence in a belief
system and they'll make change happen
i'm very passionate about this because
frankly
it only takes a few people to change the
direction of any industry or social
track
you know i think this might be a good
time to open up the floor to questions
from the audience
so we have caroline and ryan on either
side with mike's please keep your hands
raised so that one of them can spot you
you can also tweet your questions using
gsb vft and michelle here will ask you a
question actually let's start with the
question from twitter and i want to
apologize i have to leave soon after
this
but
my email address is vk coastal
ventures.com if he don't get to your
question
please feel free
to send it
thank you even though i cannot spend as
much time answering it as as much time
as you spend thoughtfully asking the
question
that that's my rule on email
i try and judge how much how thoughtful
was somebody in sending the email
yes sorry all right there's a lot of
very thoughtful questions on twitter
regarding your belief system um
can you talk about what exactly is your
core belief system and how do you foster
that in your team and your company
you know um so i decided very early i
wanted to work on interesting things
it's not well known but i started the
first program programming class at any
iit
in 1971 we formed a hobby club of four
people to learn programming and that was
the first instance i know of a
programming class at any iit
a few years later i got interested in
biomedical engineering
and i was 16 when i started the
programming club at iit delhi
a few years later we started the
biomedical engineering program which was
we just convinced one professor to work
with us and there was three or four of
us and so i had this habit of saying
what do i want to do and how to make it
happen
right
but the core belief system i have is i
want to work on interesting things i
don't want to get bored
um
and it applies to what i'm doing today
what i've learned since
is
it's nice to do that but it's even more
rewarding to do interesting things that
have a great impact
and so
i measure impact a lot
we're probably the only vc firm that in
the
first slide deck fundraising slide deck
we said we care about our ambition which
is irr but we care as much or more about
our ambition our mission which is to
make a positive change
and i've told my lps if you get a lower
rate of return
but higher impact will probably pick
that because i'm much more interested in
that than
feeding some pension fund uh slightly
higher rate of return as long as i cross
a bar
it's very clear to me
so it was
cool stuff and interesting stuff early i
didn't have perspective when i was in
20s and over time i said it's much more
fun to work on things that make a
difference and so i only do that
we we had an in
investment and somebody will tweet this
and i'll get in trouble
we are looking at an investment in a
company called teespring which is doing
extremely well
and the partner who's doing that and i
said
you know you want to invest in these tee
spraying or t-shirts great
don't expect me to spend any time
i'm not interested in t-shirts
i'd rather work on a healthcare
solution and so
it's
it's
again i'm going to emphasize this is a
luxury i've earned so all of you don't
have that luxury and you're not in the
same place and i recognize when other
people aren't in the same place
i also never cared what people thought
so
i had that luxury very early on in my
life
mostly through my attitude
which was much more belligerent when i
was young
but now i can honestly say
we built a new building a few years ago
and i said you know as long as
health permits
i've enjoyed this so much and the area
i'm working on keeps changing every few
years because the nature of venture
capital and technology i'm going to do
this for the rest of my life but only do
things that actually make a positive
difference
but also anytime you make a difference
you make money and i think when you make
money as a consequence of trying to do
build interesting companies
you make much more of an impact than if
you do it as a transaction buy sell kind
of thing
in fact if i get a plan business plan
that talks about exit in the first
couple of pages i almost never read the
rest of it
it's a good tip
right
can you hear me
um so i'm alina and i actually work for
healthcare startup but i have a pointed
question about you i'm very impressed by
the confidence you exhibit and obviously
you have reasons to be that some people
call it arrogance
um my question is did you when you were
a kid
did you get support from your family
that made you as confident as you are
right now
you know
first it's hard to remember
i always did my thing i always did
things most kids didn't do and
my parents always
sort of
i guess support is probably the right
word
indian family is very different you
never
you never did things your parents really
opposed but
i tended to do some of that
but i always had great dialogue with my
parents and they actually sort of
accepted me very early doing
going out of the bounds
for those of you interested in my
attitude and those of you who may have
kids
uh i was asked to give a talk at harker
school here in uh
you know in saratoga so i gave a talk to
the high school kids and i did a
presentation and my
first slide was something like
why you should only color outside the
lines
my second
slide was about why you should disregard
your teachers
my third one was why you should disobey
parents
um
and yeah it was sort of funny and the
kids loved it but i'm dead serious about
it
i'm dead serious about it
i actually think
inculcating an attitude of exploration
not confirmation to a bound set of
bounds set by others is what creates
this
internal compass and belief system and
confidence in yourself
again i say 90 of you
will do what's expected you know after
this you'll be motivated and then go
back and say oh that goldman job it pays
more
hi um neong mba1 thanks for your speech
um i i'm just on the analyst thing that
you mentioned um there's the vc field
now as compared to in the past has
become a lot more crowded and
there's a talk of a tech bubble here in
your opinion are we in the middle of a
bubble and if so when do you foresee it
bursting thanks
i don't i know that i don't know the
answer
i also know anybody who tells you they
know the answer is probably stupid
so yeah thanks thanks for your talk uh
pablo fuentes nba 10. um so i think your
brand of swashbuckling is particularly
effective if you show some vulnerability
so i'm going to be your buddy and allow
you to tell us a story about a time when
you got crushed by somebody's brutal
honesty and what you did with that
um
so
look um it would take an hour to talk
about all my mistakes i actually uh let
me put it this way
in the last 15 years there's only once
in my life i've called somebody and said
i'd like to speak at this conference
and that wasn't a popular conference is
a small thing in a hotel room in san
francisco and it was called failure con
where everybody who had failed came
and i wanted to speak to this issue of
failure
there are so many
stupid things you know the ipad is so
popular
we tried to do it
probably one of my
large mistakes in the late 80s
uh and i can go into details and i'll
cut it short
what i would say is i'm never
embarrassed about my failures
and so if you search on the web for my
failures you'll find lots of them and
you'll find me talking about them
it's important because given my
philosophy
where i screw up doesn't matter because
it's a long list in fact it's a longer
list than my successes but like i
started with nobody remembers the data
dump here
everybody remembers sun
right
the number of
venture companies where i made stupid
mistakes i'll tell you one of my
big failures
so if you go back to sun
1980s
sun's
logo or
model under the logo was the network is
the computer
and these couple of people started this
software program that did routing of ip
packets so network traffic
that happened to be the beginning of
cisco
now when you say the network is the
computer
and make these arrogant
marketing lines and you forget that
routing is the key element
and cisco was born as an application on
sun and we didn't see it
and i said to myself duh how stupid was
i not to see it when it was happening
even when i saw the application
a router was an application on a sun
machine we missed the largest
opportunity sun could have i can find a
hundred such examples
the point is
try and fail but don't fail to try
my a couple of other
favorite quotes along those lines since
we're coming to the end of our time
um
robert f kennedy said only those who
fail greatly can succeed greatly
the classic example of that is elon musk
right
he said forget this [ __ ] about
supplying batteries to gm
they're just too slow to make change
happen
you know i was talking about retailing
amazon not walmart
youtube not nbc
think about gm or tesla
gm spent way more money than tesla did
space nasus and lockheed spent way more
money than spacex did i can go on and on
every major change
so failure
try and fail but don't fail to try
naseem talib in his book anti-fragile
which i recommend everybody read if
they're setting off on a career as a
personal philosophy
mine happens to coincide and i'm not
talking about black swan but his book
called anti-fragile
i always love ending with a
good red book recommendation
i think that's important so
i'm just not embarrassed about my stupid
mistakes i mean i think that's the
difference
i don't know if i answered your question
when did i get crushed
by brutal honesty i mean i've offended
plenty of people
and that
show
i won't go into the details because a
public company or two public companies
are involved but
uh i was on a
on a panel with the ceo of this public
company and i basically told them how
stupid they were and then
there was payback in an indirect way and
that really hurt this other company and
it
you know literally killed almost killed
the company
unfortunately because they're public
companies i won't go into details so
that's an example where brutal honesty
really hurt me
um
i can think of lots of people look
there's plenty of people in the vc
business that don't like me because
i tell them they they're sort of
worthless
i do
but again it's an indulgence on my part
the really good people i don't say that
to
if i don't know somebody enough i won't
say that to them
but if i do know for sure i do make sure
i tell them more importantly i tell the
entrepreneurs what i think and they
often tell the vc
it's part of life you know i want to
make sure we have time for one more
question um actually a quick
announcement before that um friends of
roanoke from the class of 2010 are
welcome to join his family backstage
after the event ends to share stories
and reminisce
um so
this question has become sort of a view
from the top tradition um and every
applicant to stanford gsb is asked this
question on their application
however you were not asked this question
in 1978 because this question didn't
exist in 1978 it started in 2000s so
here's your chance to answer this
question
what matters most to you and why
you know i think it's sort of
and i won't phrase this in uh
in a do-gooder kind of way and i don't
mean it that way i just find it's cool
to disrupt things for the better
and so when i say impact i sort of feel
like i'm being a troll on various
industries and it's a luxury i've earned
to because i don't need to pay my
mortgage
and so
i like taking on new things
you know it's sort of like enough people
are mad at me for saying we don't need
doctors i actually don't believe we do
so
but we need them a different kind of
doctor to do a different kind of thing
and i wouldn't go to
stanford med school to get the best
doctors i'd go to ucla film school
because the human element of care is
important then acting becomes important
and that's where most of our doctors
will come from in 15 years for the human
element of care
and people hate it doctors hate it when
i say
to get the most
most of the human element of care you
need the most humane humans and those
aren't the high iq people who got into
stanford med school
reality
but
what i would say is
knowing i can make a difference in
industries where things are positive is
very rewarding
and let me end on the note that
i actually like working on things that
my four kids would be proud of me
working on right
and there's this question that all of
you will face of work-life balance so
let me end on that note
working on cool things
excites me keeps me motivated i like to
say
you retir you grow old when you retire
not you you don't retire when you grow
old and as long as you're stimulated and
excited and whatever your passion is
and it can be what i do
it could be i want to train them well
i find that a really hard task
it's a difficult challenge by itself
maybe it's not hugely impactful for
society but i actually love that example
of if i got passionate about that and
did that and it's a really hard thing to
do
it'd be exciting to go pursue it so i
like hard challenges i like difficult
things i like working against the odds
and that
brings out my comparative spirit and now
i happen to constrain it to areas where
i think i can have a positive impact
but not so much in the do-gooder thing
it's a luxury i can indulge in it makes
my kids feel better so let me end there
through all of the 90s when my kids were
young i had one rule
this
15-minute thing managing my time came
from the following
i realized it was easy for all of us
to say things and then in mean them and
not stay true to them
the most important family
everybody says the right words
they
don't live by them so what i decided i'd
do is get a monthly report
of every category of time
i spent time on
it could be working with entrepreneurs
evaluating new companies being polite
talking to journalists
being polite because somebody said hey
my son wants to talk have a conversation
i classified my time into 20 categories
one of the most critical lines in that
was the number of times
i had dinner with my kids at home
and i set an impossible goal of 25 times
a month
and it took me a year or so but
eventually i met it but more importantly
every month i had a report on whether i
did or didn't
i do believe work-life balance is
possible
you just have to be extremely
disciplined about it
i no longer went to the pub right
although
i no longer
did
baseball games with friends i only did
it with my kids or son
i
i decided what my priorities were
explicitly and then measured it to meet
the requirements i highly recommend you
come up with your own priorities and
measure them
thank you all very much
you